and I see women my age just investing in
like all of this plastic surgery a pound
of all this stuff and guys I I I don't
even have a problem with light plastic
surgery I don't even really have a
problem with light minimal stuff but you
guys are just it's getting crazy you
guys are getting ridiculous can you show
me examples of women that are I don't
know in the top 5 10% of beauty that
they aged okay or a little better than
most as as a point of oh oh women are
hot they they stay hot forever no you
don't no woman is that attractive after
35 she just becomes a average normal
woman and before you bring up JLo
do you look like JLo none of you look
like JLo so stop bringing up these
exceptional women that you don't look
like